[Musik]
dort wird präsentiert von toyota hybrid
cloud keine steckdose und fällt trotzdem
elektrisch
der alpsommer ist zu ende
aber schon bald steigen die schwarzen
eringer kühe in den kampf ring und dann
will die 16-jährige natalia bracke
unbedingt mit ihrer eigenen kuhn in der
arena stehen
[Musik]
natalias vater marco buggy ist ein
erfolgreicher züchter dieser walesa
kuras
[Musik]
noch hat natalia einen winter lang zeit
den kampf vorzubereiten
sie will ihre lieblingskuh cascada in
den ring schicken ich das mal geboxt hat
das hat einfach nicht mehr los
versucht nicht übertreiben
also einfach wieder schafft von
adrenalin
was ist da los
[Musik]
ganz gut denn du bist
ich hatte gar 22 44
es ist zwar umgangen mein vater hat mir
gesagt wenn ich es toll wie also kann
der islam das was ich für das rollbett
und danach nicht aktiv das ist irgendwie
minis und nachhaltig getrennt und das
ist da halt gefunden und jetzt schon
fünf jahren sitzt der ball sachs und
drei begleiter und ich immer eine stunde
bemerkt wie mein problem
jahrhunderts und die tür ist einfach
wichtig als dass ich vier oder fünf
tagen holte und ich immer stark
umstritten zeit also wirst du später mit
der würde stache gesetze einfach so als
slice dass ich irgendetwas was
widerstand heimischen garten
[Musik]
cascada ist gut ein jahr alt und noch
nicht ausgewachsen
doch sie bringt bereits mehr als 400
kilo auf die waage
[Musik]
natalia lebt den tod
ein typisches walliser dorf im rhonetal
der zucht stall der familie liegt mitten
im dorf die hauptstraße verbindet war
das unter mit dem oberwallis doch kaum
jemand kommt auf die idee hier
anzuhalten
[Musik]
das erste steht fest dieser saison die
kämpferinnen warten ungeduldig auf ihren
einsatz
ihre besitzer sind teil einer
eingeschworenen gemeinschaft außerhalb
des rings gute bekannte im ring
konkurrenten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die kühe von dem paradies kämpfen in der
schwersten gewichtsklasse bevor die
nummer 10 wird für sie in den ring
steigen markus stallung heißt dorna
blick für den kampf ziehen sich vater
und tochter die menschen mit den
teameigenen faden über beim herbst
ringkampf dürfen nur trächtige kühe
kämpfen
die tiere dürfen weder günstig noch stil
süchtig sein und auch sonst keine
anderen zeichen von aggressivität
aufweisen
der tierarzt muss mit einem ultraschall
bestätigen dass alles regelkonform läuft
[Musik]
geld kann er wie vor wer als läuft
darauf hoffen
gates und mit wlan und hofer das
gegenrecht das sind wir natürlich
channel mit
ja und eine party halloween ist egal
kochen
[Musik]
zu gewinnen gibt es ruhm und ehre und
kuhglocken sogenannte 34
für die züchter ein heiß begehrte
auszeichnung die kühe werden in gruppen
in den ring geführt treiber sorgen dafür
dass in paaren gekämpft wird die kühle
suchen sich ihre partnerinnen selber aus
wer zurückweicht verliert
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich laufe der arbeit
eine jury beurteilt die kämpferinnen
marcus kuhl buchung die nummer 10 geht
in den kampf
[Musik]
am ring ist natalia eine der wenigen
frauen und definitiv eine der jüngsten
[Musik]
hi
weil ich spontan
[Musik]
dieses mal gibt es keinen sieg für marco
ist verletzt
[Musik]
wie kommst du aber die ideen der
schmerzmittel spritzen in der schule ja
aber wenn sie sich nicht das frühzeitig
aus ist für marco eine enttäuschung aber
das fest lässt er sich nicht verderben
[Musik]
meist aber gehörte marco zu den
gewinnern im gare nutzer typischen
walliser trinkt stube sammelt er alle
seine trophäen die 34
die wichtigsten sind die kantonalen die
sich aber sehr optimistisch
umfangreiche aktion und wird immer der
kampf ist auch gespielt und überall und
heime doch eigentlich mit wer brot und
nach eine stille die zucht und immer
wieder züchter und meine dinge ist
einfach die zucht hallwachs und der
wolke sich ein supervulkan engagement
immer nicht immer rum club ihrem kleid
aber die mehr so schlachter die ich war
erste priesen den zuschlag aber es geht
auch immer wieder junge genauer und dass
ich sterbe des islams hoch und tief ich
so noch und damit genau die rauskam
france und das ist mir geglückt bei dem
herr das ist so wie ich das aber dass
die aber nicht immer nur da und jetzt
klar dass china importiere mit das ist
schön und gibt also viel wie möglich mit
sie kann nicht alles mika war bei der
wahl am 6
und so sehen wir noch jede fest sicher
und probierte das ist vaters fußstapfen
sind ziemlich groß natal hat sich viel
vorgenommen als sie sich entschlossen
hat ihm zu folgen
[Musik]
das konnte bach gehört ist ein guter
brüssel rpo
ihr habt schon woche
fehlermeldungen
ja
minute rein gesetzt war der später
endlich das problem sie will einfach mal
an der stelle trotz durchaus schwer und
noch als klammer verbringen
das muss ich doch hatte der machen
natalia macht eine zweijährige an lehre
in einer landmaschinen werkstatt
[Applaus]
eine volle ausbildung kann ihr der
betrieb hier nicht bieten
sie wird gezwungen sein sich bald
umzuorientieren
ich bin also ich bin ich dass ein
manchmal wird im herbst oft 24 stunden
damit jemand dem zahnmobil das gänge
mehr das nicht irgendwie zum beispiel
das ist nunmal mancher und nachhaltig
geschafft wirklich noch mal mit der man
show und ich glaube ich wäre mit zehn
mann
[Musik]
breisach kreis spiele haben und ich nur
mit man druck also im moment spielt und
ja ich war eine hüpfburg sowie ist
länglich im minimal proxy und ja also
nicht endlich marienburg spielen das ist
nicht gut das problem nur als kollegen
mit frauen sehr viel komplizierter
klebt an ihm ihr sonstiger billabong
stoll als gallier und ja ich fast
gestanden
und noch jemand mit wasser und ich
glaube bislang 58 wichtig das buch sage
war war dieser mann ist sinnvoller
ich wollte
das galt auch für dynamiker ich fühle
mich mit damit arbeiter wohl und es
stimmt nämlich also von daher kann die
dann wieder arbeitsmarkt kann mit einem
risiko
und wenn er bissig beschneiden heime für
mich
welchen träumen eifern jugendliche in
dieser gegend nach wenn die traum lehre
unerreichbar ist
ich verschaffe ich denke ich ein simpler
man ihren job verschaffen
was ist in zwei jahren weil sich sagen
bereits zwei aber nicht einen job
wer sicher dass nur wenige kreis wird
wenn ihr auch stand ich bin schon und
ich weiß nicht
ich hoffe sie noch weiter schaffen er
vor richter
ich zeige ich euch den priora ist oder
so spitz vorliegt ein manchmal reise
durch zudem ist davon alles kaputt
also ich fix in front
wovor erholt sich von ihrer verletzung
und schaut ihren jüngeren
mitstreiterinnen auf der weide zu
eringer kühe kämpfen auch außerhalb des
rings
auf der steilen alt kann das schon mal
zum verhängnis werden
bei so einem kampf stürzte ausgerechnet
mit alias cascada und hat sich verletzt
[Musik]
cascada im frühling kämpfen kann
wie schwer ist ihre verletzung natalia
und ihr vater wollen es genau wissen
hier noch nicht
so weber
das parlament bringen
[Applaus]
marco wird ein geschultes auge auf
cascada stein ein schwaches bein würde
eine schwache kampfkuh bedeuten unter
schmerzen könnte cascada ihren ersten
kampf nicht bestreiten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
warum
naja
alles bestens
die familie weiß nicht recht wie weiter
und dreht sich vater und tochter sehen
sich gezwungen das wallis zu verlassen
und trat in der wüste schweiz zu holen
das berner tierspital zur klarheit
schaffen
[Musik]
sie habe
haben die august nach und nach besser
kommen und linken
einfach hier und da hat jede botschaft
und modlos und ich trug und der kino.to
spitz so und der heimat nur geringen ist
allerdings schwer
ja
[Musik]
aber man ist die tage hier lernen sie
glauben wollen die nex cavete bei seinen
gesprächen
[Musik]
hochstimmung bei der besucher und der
wenigen stellschrauben
[Musik]
der bau
[Applaus]
natalia lässt kaskade nicht gerne allein
in bern schweren herzens muss sie die
auswertung der rentenberatung
[Musik]
natalia hat noch eine leidenschaft vom
vater geerbt eishockey
heute wird sie ablenkung suchen die
angst um ihre juli für einen moment
vergessen ja auch geklappt dann hinter
das schon eher
[Applaus]
natalia kämpft als nummer 54
[Musik]
[Applaus]
früher spielte natalia zusammen mit
jungs in der u16 nationalmannschaft das
niveau war hoch das spiel um einiges
rauer
jetzt bei ihrem frauenteam sind
bodychecks nicht mehr erlaubt
[Applaus]
für dieses foul muss sie auf die
strafbank ihrer meinung nach ein
fehlentscheid des schiedsrichters
sie findet das gegnerische mädchen stand
ihr einfach im weg
[Musik]
sie wissen schon
[Gelächter]
über den sieg ihres teams kann sie sich
deshalb nicht wirklich freuen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ihre freundin gefühle und physisch ist
er gerade und darüber konnte dadurch
zwölfjährige glaube ich dann wieder so
mancher schauen sich an der hüfte ist
auch empfindlich ist das klar und welche
personen der welt
wir hoffen also wieder nach linie
ministerium erklärte und möchte diese
abdrehen wieder landschaft das sag ich
mal wieder unterstellt dass sie weiter
schwach
seit der scheidung ihrer eltern sieht
natalia ihre mutter nur noch selten
sie wohnt mit natalias bruder im
nachbardorf
der profi
und das bekommen
[Musik]
während der einfach kommen immer mehr an
die iss aber ich finde es verständlich
verschiedene da einfach gesehen und für
mich sah in der khl einfach sie
schalteten und innert acht neue frauen
habe ich glaube dass nie einfach
vertreter von vor allem für kinder das
zu akzeptieren
das gefühl dass die schnittmenge morgen
machen sie einfach mehr schwer
natürlich mit normaler oder so
[Musik]
noch gehen marco und metaller davon aus
dass cascada im frühling kämpfen will
[Musik]
als weitere vorbereitung besuchen sie
zusammen mit vaters neuer freundin kathi
ein wichtiges stichfest in martin
[Musik]
dass er wie hier
und auch für künftige schäden auf der
donau
[Musik]
kampf für wollen offenbar nicht immer in
den ring steigen so zumindest scheint es
[Musik]
[Applaus]
endlich ist die diagnose aus dem tier
spital eingetroffen
cascada hat eine schwer heilbare
knochenverletzung die tagung war krank
die moral für die operativen aber leider
ist das abonnieren
der mini ist früher und ich habe mich
verbrannt in hof niedriger sein als
damals und ich habe mich darauf gefreut
auf den ganzen verein alles ist bereit
auf 63 wird dass der stammtisch
playstation
das macht derweil am harz traum
zu hause in zucht stein nach ersten
schwierigkeiten hat sich natalia partie
der neuen frau an vater seite angenähert
das sind wirklich ein riesen freitag
zwischen familie und da caccia dass mir
die schweizer klären was motivation
mitra und es ziehen fordert ihm
verweigert so zeige ein kondensator für
lieber nicht irgend einen schlag
verschwinden kann
[Musik]
hamburg
das eigentlich immer dass ich als großes
die stanz thema kreierten raums kann man
eher mit mord kamen bis jungs denken wir
dachten da nicht
[Musik]
ja und ja so weh aber auch nie minute
so schnell kann s nicht
natalia hallo hallo
[Musik]
und so schauen sie nur wie reserviert
auf sonntag wurde erst recht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
kritischere drehen warum
[Musik]
so werde entschieden wann ich gehe
die verletzung und mein leben ob es
gleich noch nie ist das wirklich besser
werden du bringst verletzt der nähe von
lodz beobachten wie das geht und noch
einmal entscheiden so lang dass dieses
problem warum das ist die schlacht
[Musik]
cascada wird kaum je in einen ring
steigen
aber vorläufig garantieren ihr ihre
guten gene ein langes leben als zucht
kuh und die zwei werden vorerst nicht
getrennt
[Applaus]
natalia und ihre beste freundin natascha
teilen die liebe zu den pferden
mit ihnen lebt sie ihre feinfühligen
seite aus großer und groove und das gibt
mir so einfach so der ist sensibler
spieler und kathrin taktik spielt und
das hat mir einfach schön mehr geht im
labor wolle das einfach mal so
[Applaus]
höhen und tiefen gab es mehr der
freundschaft geht ob er will einfach
immer wieder zusammengefunden
ja was soll das sein soll das muss immer
wieder gemerkt so einfach ich mich ab
und zu probleme und aber schlussendlich
etwas bringt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
auch kredite aufnehmen
es ist von ihm geworden hier hätte in
natalia mit cascada im ring kämpfen soll
ihr großer traum ihre erste glocke zu
gewinnen ist geplatzt
sie bleibt papas engagierter learning
[Musik]
familie warum pro box und ich und es
wird man schon mal da sind bis cattolica
co aber ich habe 60 sekunden
[Musik]
waschen erklärt hat scheint mir ja du
auch keine chance ließ
[Musik]
das koste sagen
oh mein gott
[Musik]
ein solcher bau spenden 26
es hat nicht sein sollen aber natalia
gibt nicht auf vielleicht gewinnt sie
später eine krake der schritt ins
erwachsenenleben steht er auf jeden fall
bevor ich ganz viele - aber fehler und
wenn man nicht panische angst will
ich glaube da ist einfach so eine große
verantwortung
damit notiert das alles was ich nicht
dass ich die verantwortlichen stolz
einig dass das überlasse ich glaube man
mit ja dann verantworten könnte man denn
es waren angst aber zwar sagen das ist
das nicht dass drei erklären dass ich
das nicht schaffen
dass dazu kommt
[Musik]
doch was halt die zukunft jetzt für
natalia bereit
sie plant einen ersten kleinen schritt
in die unabhängigkeit
also wer sie im studio auf dem stein und
jeweiliger stoxx kabul
wenn es möglich ist
aber es fehlt nicht ein freies europa
die kolleginnen und kollegen aber ich
bin mit dieser person aber nicht einig
minute zwei kolleginnen sind ja alter
mann ich will ich einmal so kühl hat die
coole spät und nicht offen und hänge
steil und ja also na ja die wohnung
geben und was ich mich daran teil wie
ihr papa hier schon mal hab ich kenne
ich immer wollte nicht ernst genug sie
und das gefällt mir schon vorstellen
dass dann auch werde ich noch im stall
und wieder standen heime und einfach
schön heimelig und dann würde dich gerne
hätte
minuten jetzt gefühl dass der regen wir
mehrere schauen denn das kontrollieren
das so und ich glaube wenn ich noch
allerlei bono würde da das akzeptiere
das sind gewisse privatsphäre geht weiß
also sagen wenn der zweiten tag für mich
und das europa nicht wert will er
schaffen
das ist das würde mich nicht stetig b am
morgen aber im stall quandt lichteffekte
wie seine kollegen und mich als
verteiler sowie problem hauen
da half dem reise der situation im
scheiß wilhelm ii
ich war
[Musik]
inzucht stall steht caspar das schicksal
noch nicht fest immerhin hat sich ihr
bein gebessert zweimal wurde sie bisher
zum stier geführt zweimal verlor sie ihr
kälbchen normalerweise das todesurteil
für eine zucht von natalia hofft aber
noch immer auf ein drittes erfolgreiches
mal also das heißt wenn es sind als
preis schon probleme mit der tracht ist
das lacht schwer noch früher sind und da
denkt man probleme am start
damit darf ich ja nichts machen da
dachte ich mir ich sollte die wirtschaft
fast also rasch einerseits schmusekatze
daheim aber von der hals verschuldet
was ist da und setzte alle minihof nicht
darauf dass streit und und wenn nicht
ja auch überall grinsen und nimmt da
kriegen sie denn immer öfter und alle
guten dinge sind drei und der wird das
schon
[Musik]
dort wurde präsentiert von toyota hybrid
cloud keine steckdose und fällt trotzdem
elektrisch